bambi et merci beaucoup de nous recevoir
ici chez vous le feu on est à quelques
jours de cette commémoration dans quel
état d'esprit vous êtes je suis triste
pour les victimes
je suis triste où la famille et j'espère
que l'avenir c'est la meilleure qu'il
ait passé comme vous l'appelez les 3
février quand j'appuie la parole à
québec
quand j'ai dit que il faut qu'il
appelait d'un avion biais 2010 7 soit
complètement différent de l'avant 29
janvier 2017
est ce qu'il est vraiment très design or
il est pas très différent il est un peu
différent mais pas énormément on fait du
progrès il faut pas céder c'est
désespéré mais il faut pas s'asseoir
chez notre gloire on dira tout est beau
tout est pas bien passé puis là
maintenant on est une famille unie puis
on les gars de larminat on a encore
beaucoup de chemin à faire
est-ce qu'on se souvient il quand même
cet énorme élan de solidarité il ya un
espoir que des fonds allaient être bâti
parce que c'est ça que vous vouliez les
longs des solidarités j'avais
le cachot je me suis dit voilà
finalement on sent qu'on lit même
famille tony cocon c'est légal les yeux
dans les yeux on va les gars bel avenir
ensemble il y avait cet élan de
solidarité des gens de toutes origines
de toutes les religions du tout qui
toutes les classes politiques étaient
unis à dire non à la haine non à la
violence donc c'était bien mais comme je
dis de cette époque là il faut qu'on
passe des paroles à l'acte il plutôt
qu'ils soient justes émotionnelles il
faut que ce soit un projet de société
c'est qui est fin et ce qui est bien on
trouve que la classe politique en
général les médias en général il ya un
bon changement avant la tragédie
moi je l'appelle la tragédie parce que
c'est une tragédie les jeunes et les
médias en général parler des nous plutôt
de nous parler et se vont ils pas les
deux noms mal plutôt de vous parler
maintenant juste les faits que vous
soyez chez nous ici assez rémy c'est une
grave et oui effectivement notre voix
commence à 7h30 on démonte pas un
traitement de faveur mais seulement
quand nous en tant qu on nous pose les
questions que nous donne la chance de
ces débats de discuter et d'argumenter
et
et d'expliquer notre point de vue ça je
trouve qu'on a fait des pas de géants de
ce côté là et c'est bien
les politiciens en général ils sont
beaucoup plus attentifs qu'avant et plus
sensible qu avant c qui est bien même
quand on a parlé dernièrement de la
nécessité d'avoir décrété les 29 janvier
comme il joue menait contre
l'islamophobie
c'est vrai ça n'a pas passé est déçu
déçu mais pas surpris et il y a des
éléments positifs beaucoup de gens mais
dit doughty va chercher tout cet
optimisme
ce qui est positif c'est le suivant
avant on nier l'existence d'
islamophobie
c'était ccb d'utiliser cet exemple dur
mais c'était comme l'inceste dont l'un
cesse dans une famille les personnes qui
veut parler l'inceste et même si la
victime ose parler de l'inceste
on lui fermer la gueule et puis on
l'accusé d'avoir déshonoré la famille
plutôt qu'ils s'assoient l'agresseur qui
déshonorait la famille c'est elle la
victime
on accusait la victime dd l'insead et
déshonoré la famille mais maintenant
puis c'était la même chose pour
l'islamophobie
si quelqu'un parler de l'islamophobie
comme si on parlait contre la société
québécoise qui est pas vrai maintenant
on a encore ressenti comme ça
aujourd'hui mais non la malaise est
toujours mais pas à 100%
on a remarqué qu'ils aient beaucoup des
politiciens même ceux qui sont objectés
disais oui ça existait mais on diffère
comment les guérés ce qui est un pas en
avant mais comment est ce que vous
comprenez quand même ce malaise qui
existe parce que beaucoup de québécois
quand on a parlé de cette journée contre
l'islamophobie se sont senti
personnellement visé comme si on les
accusés eux d'être islamophobe
oui il y a de l'islamophobie dans la
société on peut pas se cacher beaucoup
des gens voulaient se cacher derrière
alexandre bissonnette
on disait baisse ilizi l'oeuvre d'un
seul homme désolé je suis jamais passé à
ses points de vue parce que si jeune
homme est en prison si jeune homme va
suivre son procès probablement qu'il va
passer toute sa vie en prison
mais le problème n'est pas réglé même
après que ces messieurs là c'est gênant
mais ton plaisant il à l'auto du
président du conseil de la mosquée qui
étaient incendiées il y aller les colis
et nus qu'on avait su à la mosquée à
québec l'été être même de la tuerie il y
avait le référendum à saint-apollinaire
avec toute la propagande haineuse sur la
symétrie lynch et me tiens il l'est tout
ce qu'on a entendu ça ça fait dresser
les cheveux sur la tête
donc il y à ces malaises et c'est pas
tous les québécois ça certains il y à
une minorité mais une minorité très
active très bruyante est très nuisible
qui est très actif sur les médias
sociaux comme disait quelqu'un si un
quelqu'un vient d'une autre planète
ici au québec qui régatent 6 passionne
les médias sociaux aussi les
commentaires sur les articles dans les
journaux il va penser qu'on est toute
une société des racistes et des
xénophobes baudet d'islamophobe non
caler mon nom gilles queille parce que
si j'accuse le québécois d'être
islamophobe parce que j'aime acquise moi
même d'être islamophobe parce que moi
aussi je suis québécois ma femme est
québécoise mais on pense aux québécois
les québécois ne sont pas islamophobe
les québécois sont pas racistes la
preuve l'existence dé tous ces néo
québécois qui sont ici bien que moi même
ça a généré cette tragédie un an
beaucoup de peur dans la communauté
musulmane et mosquées sont quand même
plus protégés aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup
de gens qui nous disent encore qu'il ne
participe pas à certaines à certaines
cérémonies ou des choses comme ça parce
qu'ils ont quand même peur est ce que
cette peur elle est encore là un an
après on est encore en sécurité les
québec n'est pas l'afghanistan les
québec n'est pas la somme adulé québec
n'est pas l'irak
on est en sécurité ici mais
malheureusement oui il y a encore des
éléments qui sont dangereux il faut
qu'on les identifie et pas pour protéger
à singulier où les enfants d un
singulier sypros protéger la société
québécoise en général je vais dire des
propos des fois chacha quelques musées
mangez moi là comme si on vous avait
parlé de
l'alexandrie sonel comme une victime il
avait chaque srgc
puis j'ai percé cgeci mais c'est
beaucoup plus facile d'être un mur qui
est d'être un pont un mur de séparation
il est là il ya personne qui les
dérangent mais un pan tout le monde doit
passer par dessus les autos les
bicyclettes les trains et les gentils
les moins gentil mais c'est beaucoup
plus utile et d'être un pont pitot
d'être un mur de séparation et moi j'ai
choisi parce que j'aime pas les choses
faciles j'ai choisi de très bons essais
pour s'agit subi des fois un pont ça
vibre à moi aussi mais je persiste
merci beaucoup et manier pour cet enfant
et merci beaucoup